no stranger to being written about but
soon he's setting the record straight in
his own words the provocative title
alone an indication that the Duke of
Sussex hasn't held back after taking
over TV with that Netflix documentary
series soon Prince Harry's Memoir will
be joining these coming to a Bookshop
near you there is no escaping his truth
no matter how cynical you might be it is
a story that will sell helping Harry was
former journalist turned novelist and
Ghost Writer J.R murringer who also
wrote Andre agassi's award-winning
autobiography and is perhaps a kindred
spirit his own Memoir the subject of
this Ben Affleck film about a young
boy's search for surrogates to replace
his absent father baby you could become
a writer it's about the importance of
love and seeing somebody and validating
them and telling them you know being
honest with them and telling them hey
you're going to be okay you're loved
you're worth something things are gonna
work for you
it Ghost Writer Andrew Crofts has
written more than 80 books for other
people including some celebrity
bestsellers it's quite good to have an
American Ghost in This Book because
they're coming to it with less
background knowledge
so they're actually going to be asking
questions that I would probably as an
Englishman who's lived through the whole
Crown story from from you know all
through my life I wouldn't bother to ask
because it's so sort of it's taken as
read
um so they for so if you're appealing to
a global market is this as Harry is
um it's good to have somebody who maybe
who's slightly outside in their six
hours
William
blamed to the
metering a miscarriage coming just weeks
after that can there really be any more
fireworks I have a lot of sympathy for
them they did not like the life they
were in I can't imagine there's anything
else to say
um unless they have more barbs to uh
point at their own family his words once
again set to make life difficult for the
royal family who walked away from well
they might be Keen to draw a line under
the drama given that Prince Harry has
reportedly been paid around 30 million
pounds for a four book deal it is
impossible for the palace to get a read
on what he'll say next
Katie Spencer's guy news